you've written hit songs for other
people you gave the rolling stones their
first hit song
you're a generous human being the thing
is the scene was generous
we were all so excited that we were down
in london
and we were all got recording contracts
you know so it wasn't like any animosity
i mean you know there is a rivalry but
it's not
a bad one it's kind of it's creative
it's a good thing i think you know
we would ring up the stones and say
when's your single coming out say oh
june 30th
okay well we'll put us july 30th but
it's funny
i did the rolling stone cover with
taylor swift
and she just emailed me recently
and she said i wasn't telling anyone but
i've got another album
and she said so i was going to put it
out on
my birthday which i think was the 10th
and then she said
but i found out you were going to put it
out on the 10th
so i moved to the 18th and then she
found out
we were coming out on the 18th so she
moved back to the 10th
so i mean you know people do keep out of
each other's way
right no that's nice that's a nice thing
to do you know
have you ever written songs for people
and not taken any credit
in other words would we be shocked to
learn today that you wrote a song for
such and such and it actually became a
hit and you
never ever even mentioned that you
helped out on that or wrote it i used
the
pseudonym bernard webb so i wrote a song
for peter and gordon
and i've i've used a couple of
pseudonyms but it becomes known
it gets out right you know you know so
they had a hit with it and they said oh
it was just bernard webb and it kind of
leaked out that it was me